i was found in a box on a battlefield
i'm emanuel kelly and this is my story
i was found on a battlefield in iraq by
soldiers
taken to an orphanage without any birth
certificates
passports or identity and for the next
seven years i was raised by mother
teresa nuns
where i experienced and saw gunshots
executions
experienced bombings going off hearing
noises every day that i didn't
understand
that's also where i met my now brother
ahmed who is
an amazing individual i always say the
only thing thicker than blood is love
ahmed's not my biological brother but i
love him more than words can ever
ever explain whilst i was in that
orphanage for the next seven years
we knew it was up to us to take care of
these kids
we would have one meal a day at 4 p.m
every day and we would have to feed
these kids change their diapers
do all the things that a 30 year old
would do at the age of five
eventually this exceptional woman moira
kelly
who's a humanitarian who has changed
thousands of kids lives over the years
had heard about my brother and i while
she was in albania of all places
looking after kids at a mother teresa
orphanage as well
she gets on a plane and and heads out to
uh
to to iraq eventually arrives at this
orphanage
after spending an eight hour trip from
jordan to iraq
in a taxi with someone that doesn't
speak english for three days straight i
sat on a window ledge waiting
and waiting and waiting thank god for my
brother
even though i had moments where i felt
alone because of him
he reminded me every now and then
whether it was through singing to me
that i wasn't alone
and finally on the third day she arrived
and i remember thinking three things
number one
can she help us will she help us number
two
is she an angel she was wearing a white
dress with a blue veil over her head and
i thought to myself this could be the
moment where
my life could literally change and
number three how the heck did this white
woman get in this country because she
was wider than
white chocolate and as a brown guy in
iraq
never seen a white person in my life at
the age of five she comes into the
orphanage my brother and i we start
singing
at like at the top of our lungs a
welcome song
right
but she took us out for the day i got to
see the river of babylon got to
experience iraq and we got to step out
of the walls of that orphanage for the
first time
she brought us back the end of that that
day she sat us down
my brother asked her a really serious
question he was seven at the time
auntie moya we called her auntie moira
he says can you help us
and auntie moira turns around and says
i'll do my best
i'll do my best and he goes well it's
okay moera if you can't help both
emmanuel and i
take emmanuel and maybe come back for me
another time
it took me a while i think i was about
eight years old it was after i came out
to australia
where i got told that story that's when
i realized the only thing thicker than
blood
is love it took mum two years annie
moera two years
to bring us out to australia finally we
arrived
i remember looking over the window ledge
and i thought wow
how beautiful is that we arrived into
the airport oh stop
right and i said auntie moira i'm very
very hungry and she goes no worries boys
we have spaghetti bolognese and we're
like what a spaghetti
bolognese she says ah you'll love it
right and she puts it in front of us and
we said
uh auntie moira we we need help
she goes no you don't said no we need
help
see we'd never used a knife and fork for
the first time we'd never used a spoon
for the first time
using a knife and fork was was
completely new to us
but we learnt it spaghetti bolognese is
the
hardest meal to eat there's no doubt
about it
it is i mean it goes over you it's messy
but after a while and through as my life
grew and i got bigger and older i
realized
that life is messy right we have these
moments
and life is messy that's the reality but
i learned to embrace myself so much so
that i'm sharing with you right now
doctors were able to make me a hand
and it was pretty exceptional i went to
school i had my first crush i
you know i had my first girlfriend my
first kiss i
lived a life that i would never have
lived
in iraq at the age of nine
is when i learned that i could sing and
i could sing and make money
i watched a tv show called american idol
and i watched this woman perform it was
kelly clarkson
she won the show i was inspired and i
said wow
she can do what i can as well that same
year i did my first
public performance in front of a bunch
of financial planners and accountants
financial planners are fun accountants
boring
and everyone in the audience clapped la
cut two years later at age 11 i
performed again this is the first time i
realized
i want to pursue music for the rest like
this is what i want to do for the rest
of my life i want to be a singer for the
rest of my life i want to be an artist
an entertainer
i want to disrupt the music industry
this was the first time i realized
i wanted to be the first differently
abled pop success
i sung imagine now remember that at 11
years old was when i first sung imagine
i got three standing ovations cut
to age at 14.
i sung for the prime minister of
australia i went in i met him i shook
his hand
and he says you're gonna become big two
years later i got my citizenship at age
16 my brother was 18 i got my
citizenship and it was
the best day of my life i had two
incredible days in my life at this point
the day i arrived in australia
and the day i got my citizenship because
for the first time ever the woman that
has been taking care of both my brother
and i
for the last eight years of our lives
we could call mum we finally felt like
we belonged
at 17 years of age i auditioned for x
factors i remember learning home by
michael buble and the reason i resonated
with that song so much is because
i think wherever you are in the world
home is where love is i mean that's the
message right
and i'm terrified i'm nervous i'm
waiting and finally they call my name
this guy andrew furs and uh he says to
me now emmanuel are you ready
to sing imagine by john lennon i said no
i i'm singing home
he says no dude we couldn't get the
rights for you to sing home by michael
buble i said
wait no no one no one no one did and he
goes
oh sorry buddy lucky i sung it when i
was 11 years old but dude i can't
remember and he goes well here's the
lyrics you got five minutes
and then finally i get to the uh
to the stage and i'm nervous
everything just slows down i'm still
massively insecure about the way i look
about my hands i'm getting ready to hide
them under my sleeve pulling it down and
down and down
and i walk on stage with my limp and i'm
nervous about that and i'm trying not to
limp
i arrive at the uh on stage
i remember ronan keating who's uh irish
guy who sung
he was big in in the uk and europe uh
with a band called boyzone right and i
was a huge fan and i remember him asking
me he goes
hey mate i said hey how you doing he
says
what's your name the rest
was history i told the story that you
all just heard
i was found in a box on a battlefield
taken to an orphanage where i was raised
there for the next seven years
experiencing noises gunshots
seeing things that i didn't understand
and the whole audience just took back
millions of you start rolling in into
youtube things go
crazy interview after interview after
interview after interview
and i'm starting to think i'm god's gift
to earth but at the same time i
i'm starting to i'm massively
overwhelmed
i started touring started seeing the
world i sold out the mgm
grand arena in las vegas i mean things
like that it was nuts
but as things go up there's always a
down point
i started to get arrogant and cocky and
i realized that it wasn't because i
necessarily thought i was the best or
anything like that
it was because i was so insecure at my
about myself that i overcompensated with
arrogance and cockiness record labels
agents managers started to discriminate
they told me i couldn't make it i wasn't
gonna make it they told me that
because i had a disability that i looked
bad for their brand
and i'm talking about every all the
labels
and forcing me to be a speaker instead
of doing what i love
what i know the world also loves it's my
passion my dream is to disrupt
my dream is to be the first differently
able pop success
i started to go into a depressive state
anxiety
depression if i heard loud noises it
would remind me of the bombs in iraq and
i would be terrified
i would have nightmares and the way to
stop that was to get on drugs drink
too much have sex with any random
stranger it was a really bad time in my
life
but one day a friend of mine he says
stay with me
on my couch and that same day
i looked at the mirror and i asked
myself emmanuel
what happened to the boy who could
survive anything
punch the mirror as hard as i could
blood on my hand
the next day my mate he bought a new
mirror put it up on the wall he said
please don't break this
and i looked at the mirror again and i
said
there you are from that day onwards
i started to say to myself embrace
yourself love yourself
embrace who you are you can do it
remember you're never alone
but then i get a call rob goldstein you
manage
smartest in in new york and says manual
a friend of mine's gone on tour and
we pitched you to perform with him we
sit down and he has me
record a video and then he turns the
phone to me and he shows me
and it says chris martin from coldplay
the biggest band in the world wanted to
perform with me
this kid from iraq a month later i
arrived in australia
i'm a surprise for my mum we didn't tell
her that this was happening and chris
martin walks in the band walks in i
high-five them well
hi three and we start rehearsing just as
i'm about to hop on stage with coldplay
i realized something oh no
i'm not wearing my jacket i'm just
wearing a t-shirt a white t-shirt
i'm like i gotta wear my jacket eighty
thousand people in an audience is gonna
look at me
i gotta wear my jacket then the
backstage manager
it goes to me emanuel they're ready you
gotta get on stage
it's not gonna get my jacket my boy
looks at me and he says
emmanuel you got two choices right now
you either get on that stage
or you go and get that jacket and you
don't perform the culprit
for a second i actually considered not
to perform
with the biggest band in the world
because i was still so insecure
all those memories just started rushing
back you'll never make it
i start to realize this this voice
starts screaming
at me and it's saying manual
it's none of your business what they
think about you
it's only your business what you think
about yourself
so what do you think of yourself now i
said in my head
i love me and at the end of the
performance i walked away i gave my mum
biggest hug and i said whispered in her
ear
i love you thank you i love me
today i have an album that's been
helped and mentored and by chris martin
of coldplay
it's set to come out this year in
november i have a new single that just
released never alone
a music video featuring some of the
biggest artists
in the world
[Music]
they also want to see inclusion and
diversity
really come into the forefront they want
to see mental health talked about
i am becoming the pop artist i wanted to
become
i am the first differently abled pop
success
and soon i won't be just the first
differently able pop success
i'll just be my own brand my own self
who i am a pop artist a
businessman whatever you want to say but
i'll be me
and i'll embrace every inch of that
[Music]
you